Oh awesome a brand new game from Sega to
compete with the Nintendo Wii Oh No
hey soldier what are you doing there in
the woods playing Sega that's a pretty
big tractor oh what's this guy doing my
base to steal it but he's gonna drive
around the country on that tractor and
run people over oh it's coming towards
the camera hey OH
Vsauce Kevin here this is my pop quiz
Sylvester Stallone's first movie was
rocky first blood prawn
slide it on unknowingly contribute into
the video game world when screams from
first blood and Conan the Barbarian were
digitized for Golden Axe ahh and Mortal
Kombat's Johnny Cage was originally
modeled after no not that guy but
actually jean-claude van Damme no okay
who's drunk with the camera what the
[ __ ] a few weeks ago we showed you
Mickey Mouse hidden in the original Tron
but it turns out that Mickey is
everywhere ratatouille Aladdin and all
over Disneyland go to Hidden Mickey
Guide for a full list
now let's venture into Mario's crotch
grandma not that guy's crotch
courtesy of Super Mario Land 2 and what
do we find
ball ball balls
in other news Big Bird ate Frodo well
not really but it turns out scientists
believe giant storks may have eaten
smaller early humans
scientists can't find however anyone who
can press a button faster than 16 times
per second and do this to a watermelon
finally it turns out that Sarah from a
Land Before Time is actually based on
Snooki Wow
now really but it begs the question who
is your celebrity look-alike put your
answers down in the comments below and
as always thanks for watching